Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters, and I want to explain to you really what we do in our
clinic. Our clinic has evolved over the years. I actually graduated from Northwestern
Health Sciences University is a skull right now back in 1986
So I'm kind of one of those old fogees that I've been doing this a long time really practicing what we call
Functional Medicine which we never had that term back then, but that's really how we work
We look at a functional perspective of a person's health
But God has evolved our practice in a certain way to really become a ministry. So I want to explain what we do here
First of all, we have members what we call our members our private members literally from around the globe
in nearly every continent of the world
certainly
biggest
Compliments in the United States
But this is really where our ministry is centered because we don't have people come to our facility
We don't have a facility to come to we everything is done over zoom calls in a group setting
so that we might
Practically minister to as many people as possible. This is really how God moved us
We stayed at our website that the word doctor actually means teacher and we state that because we really believe that and we really believe
This is a calling for us to educate as many people as possible
I've taken all my years of practice in taking care of people and my obsession with
Finding the truth for people and finding the cause for people and put it into our
Courses and on our private membership so that we can work with people to help them find that cause and to deal with the cause
That's why I wrote my book stop fighting cancer to start treating the cause because there's a reason why we're sick
And if we don't address the reason why though we might have to use you know different measures to help
But you know kill the disease or the cancer or whatever you still stay with your own colleges to stay with your doctor
That's not our purpose, but our purpose is to help you dig deeper. That's really what our purpose is
So we use our courses. That's where I've poured my years of experience into all of the courses that I've created
We use our private memberships through which you can get on group zoom calls
With me on a weekly basis so that I can go over your questions and try to help you work through different answers
I've created hundreds of educational videos
podcasts and through our private membership. We have I think over 900
blog posts where I'm constantly researching and posting new information trying to break it down into bite-sized pieces
For you. These are our current courses that we have right now
And certainly our flagship course is our stop fighting cancer course
That's based upon my book stop fighting cancer that I think I wrote in
Originally in 2010 and we've updated it multiple times
It really
Why we created the course was because goodness it's become a 600-page book and that's hard to digest
It's a lot of information and when you get a serious diagnosis
It's kind of like you're drinking from a fire host. It's really difficult to to you know
piece together the
usable
Information that you're receiving at light speed. So we took even our big book stop fighting cancer and start treating the cause
Broke it down into a course with different modules that you can follow and work through at your own timing and then through that you have the ability to add
fully program rice machine which I personally program for you
You can purchase a nutritional protocol. You can purchase our full
private membership where like I stated you can jump on our weekly Zoom calls and
Speak to me and ask me questions. So this is how we could get
Personal with people and really help them and you can learn from other people's questions
you can add a full genetic review and
There's just so much that we want to do to be able to
Give you the pieces of the tools to be able to help yourself
This is our our right machine that we sell that's fully programmed with it
Comes a free access to our frequency healing course
Which is all about the true right for how to use it because I don't want anybody to get a piece of
Therapy equipment and then have it sit there and go just don't really understand how to use it
So we actually put the course together so that you could best use it not just for you in your health condition
But for your family your loved ones. We have people that use their right machine as a ministry to others
They tell people in their church and their community to come over and use my right machine if you have a condition
It might help you and they're helping other people and using it as a ministry
So it's a great tool to have in your house
Regardless of whether you have any health conditions or not to be able to help keep yourself healthy and clean
We also have our whole genetic work up and if you purchase our genetic workup, you know
Again, I don't want anybody to receive anything from me that is a packed with information of usability
So with our full genetic work up you get our read your genes course that I created with
tons of videos that go over all the different genetic
Metabolic pathways that could be helpful for you and what to look at for that and why we look at it
Then what to do if you have defects and some different dietary things that you might want to work on and things that you could help prevent future disease
Possibly understanding your genetics. Then our flagship pieces are private full membership
With that is a private full membership website where you have access to my weekly zoom calls where you have access to a ton of other pages
including all our blog posts that I've ever created
Tons of Q&A videos detoxification help and by purchasing our full private membership
Which you do so through our course you also get free membership to all my courses that I've created so far
And ones that I will create the future. So it's just great and in benefit
Again, we're always that was my tagline forever has always been
Everything we do starts with asking why you're always asking why why do I have this problem?
That's uncover the cause. How could I treat my body better?
How can I help my cells function so they can repair themselves and my statement really is what I believe the gift of knowledge is beautiful
But it's really the application of knowledge. That's wisdom. That's life changing
So understand we're praying for you whatever decision you make
We want you to be made than prayer and to be obedient to God and all things you do
So thank you very much. Bye. Bye